right this is my guy - amazing home cook
Street food classics
[Music]
Street food gets its name because it's
cooked and eaten on the streets from the
hawker market and Asia to the New York
hotdog stands there are some great chefs
out there serving seriously delicious
food that you can eat on the go
my first recipe is a special mix of
fantastic flavors from around the world
beef tacos with wasabi mayo the great
thing about street food is anything goes
the only rule is they're gonna be really
fast and really tasty
now these tacos mix a Mexican and
Japanese flavors into a delicious meaty
mouthful first off get that pan really
nice and hot these are sterling steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
I'll add flavor Saul and pepper come on
tablespoons of olive oil in pan nice and
hot
hold the steak and lay it in always lay
away do the pan a little shake and it
stops the steak from sticking looking
for color if it sticks it's gonna burn
[Music]
while the steaks are cooking I'm going
with my super quick marinade now two
tablespoons of miso paste yes sir
fermented soybean that gives a really
nice sort of rich sweetness
tablespoon of sugar a cup of tablespoons
rice wine that gives it a really nice
vinegary kick couple of tablespoons of
olive oil salt and pepper I'm looking
for a nice sort of big rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks base all we're doing every time
is just adding more and more flavor take
your tongs and sort of flip the steak on
its back really
[Music]
offer the gas put them out just take
your knife it's all that fat there just
slice that off don't either
now in to the marinade beautiful tacos
are one of Mexico's most popular street
foods they've been made from beef pork
chicken or fish and are loaded up with
amazing sauces and spices now I want
something sort of pickly cabbage these
are Chinese cabbages slice it in half
and look at it really crisp and really
tasty
we're gonna slice that into quarters and
then just shred it and take your time to
get cabbage hair and you think are sort
of braised over cooked cabbage nothing
worse but an attacker you want freshness
and it's season chili flakes they sort
of discreetly give it a little bit of
heat your touch of rice wine vinegar
you ever got that fresh lemon juice
small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that a really good mix now I need
something just sort of bring it together
we take some wasabi paste
very hot very spicy I sort of
thumbnail-sized I'm gonna mix that a cup
of tablespoons of mayonnaise you give
that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is to sort of color them and then shape
them actually place it on the guest room
use some tongs so as not to burn
yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan from there I'm just gonna
place it on the rolling pin literally 30
seconds as it cools down the great thing
about serving tacos is people can fill
them in themselves just the way they
want them cabbage just squeeze out wet
marinade nice rustic little Mountain
mayonnaise on wait you see how soft and
delicious and almost sort of melting in
the mouth texture we've got I'm just an
amazing sirloin so doesn't really nice
see ya around the outside just nice and
pink in the middle start off with my
crispy shell back of the spoon with the
wasabi mayonnaise inside attacker just
sprinkle that delicious pickled cabbage
and then just start lining my attacker
with three or four slices touch more
for my spicy mayor that is how I've made
the perfect attacker
[Music]
when you want comfort food quick fast
food classics always deliver here are
three more of my street food favorites
all super easy but still put the gourmet
into grab-and-go this street food dish
packs of wonderful Indian influence
subtly spiced chicken wrap
got a mortar and pestle to make a spicy
marinade for the chicken cracker from
cardamom pods and add ground ginger
coriander cinnamon grated nutmeg cloves
of garlic fresh coriander lemon juice
olive oil and seasoned
now pulverize to form a paste
pour over the chicken thighs and leave
to marinate for up to two hours to cook
griddle on a high heat to get
wonderfully charred meat
[Music]
once the chicken is cooked warm through
tortilla wraps on the same griddle then
simply slice your chicken
and put your rap together
tapas shredded cabbage
chopped spring onion and your favorite
chili sauce
ready in 20 minutes sticky succulent and
utterly moorish spiced chicken wrap
[Music]
you'll find my next fast-food classic
all over America tasty chili dogs for
super quick and easy beef chili add
chopped onions to hot olive oil and cook
until soft then add chopped garlic a
teaspoon of cumin seeds and stir to
release their lovely aromatic flavor
next chili powder turn up the heat and
break beef mince into the pan ground and
seasoned add tomato puree and cook
through
next a glug a spicy Worcestershire sauce
chopped in tomatoes
dried oregano
at a sprinkle of sugar
[Music]
cook frankfurter or Brent worth sausages
bung in a bun and simply topped with a
spicy beef chili
easy and irresistible a dog worth
crossing the street for
my third Street food inspired recipe is
Vietnamese style baguette with beef
start slicing certainly steak into
strips
then simply marinate in soy sauce the
salty and runny honey the sweet and
leave up to two hours then thread your
marinated beef strips onto skewers and
pan fry in hot olive oil for the topping
which adds a lovely sour contrast break
carrot and simply leave to pickle in
rice vinegar
[Music]
next make the easy dressing simply DC's
and chop a Chile and castor sugar and
lime juice add a glug of fish sauce
slice that forget when lovely and brown
the marinated steak skewers are done
remove and add top with the pickled
carrot add cool sliced cucumber drizzle
over the spicy dressing and to finish it
off add coriander leaves
simple to make but complex in flavor
absolutely delicious
[Music]
three stunning recipes from the street
to your home guaranteed to take food on
the run to a whole new level and so
simple to do you don't need to spend a
fortune on masses of kitchen equipment
here's my quick guide to another cooking
essential frying pan for me one of my
favorites why because it's so versatile
whether you're searing the most amazing
rack of lamb cooking duck breasts out
eating chicken or even a quick omelette
we even find an egg all-in-one look for
an ovenproof frying pan with a metal
handle if you want to cook like pros by
finishing off your dish in the oven or
under a hot grill just don't forget when
you take it out the handle will be hot
if you can get a high-quality nonstick
one with a thick heavy base which will
distribute the heat evenly brilliance
like any passionate chef I want the best
ingredients I can find whether it's for
savory or sweet dishes next up my guide
to buying chocolate
chocolate gives you such an instant hit
it's well worth knowing about the good
stuff and who better to ask than
award-winning alchemists of the sweetest
kind Paul Young even when I don't want
to think about it I'm thinking about it
his cutting-edge approach to chocolate
making has won him accolades around the
world so you know shopping the best ways
to look at your chocolate bar look on
the back and look at the percentage that
gives you how much cocoa is in the bar
and the more cocoa the more rich
intoxicating flavor so the most exciting
bit is tasting chocolate good quality
fine chocolate should have that clean
snap buy to piece off and crunch it in
your teeth but stop chewing let it melt
move it around the mouth and you'll find
that by letting it melt even dark
chocolate that you had before that seems
quite bitter won't be when you too
quickly it releases tannin it releases
all the bitterness in the chocolate
letting it melt it's smoother and richer
and you get all the flavor I'm most
excitingly is it releases something into
the brain called dopamine which makes
you feel good and that's how you get
addicted to real chocolate
chocolates not just an addictive treat
it's an amazing ingredient here's my
take on which kind to use for what white
chocolate with its sweet vanilla taste
is perfect used as a dipping or pouring
sauce with fresh fruit or frozen berries
for a quick dessert creamy milk
chocolate is great for family-friendly
puddings and treats like quick baked
cakes or melt on to homemade crepes or
waffles dark chocolate is rich and
intense I like using 70% cocoa stuff use
it for ice creams that really pack a
punch
100% pure cocoa has a very powerful
intense taste and only the real
chocolate gigs eat it straight
and remember chocolate isn't just for
sweet dishes for the famous Mexican
Murli sauce this is the one to grab is
there anything better than chocolate
they say sex 5 doesn't totally operated
chocolate is the key ingredient in my
favorite sweet fast food dishes which at
their best are always irresistible
instant and utterly satisfied
so when you want an indulgent chocolate
hit my next recipe we right up your
alley mock chocolate donuts street food
is all about satisfying your cravings
these donuts are sweet sticky and
absolutely delicious
first off we're gonna make the dough now
this dough takes a bit of time that's
really exciting I'm heating all of the
milk with the sugar this yeast easy to
get hold off when you make fresh donuts
you need fresh yeast and examine the
warm milk to the yeast will activate it
which will help the dough to rise just
half give that a quick whisk the sugars
dissolved in the milk the fresh yeast
disintegrates instantly set the yeast
mixture to one side while it does its
job
to start the main dough mix I'm adding
half the butter to the remaining milk
that gives the dough a nice silkiness I
want it light so melt the butter into
the milk flour into a sip that helps to
make the dough nice and smooth and you
know what when you got a smooth dough it
sort of Rises evenly add a pinch of salt
and two egg yolks
pouring the warm milk and melted butter
don't start over mixing it and you over
mix the dough or doughnut it gets really
tight you don't let it area yeast in
nice and warm I love that smell now I'm
looking for a sort of elasticy texture
just dropping off the spoon nice flour
the board take the dough out
lovely lightly sprinkle touch me flower
just pull it over and push him
maybe time you sort of turning it almost
like you're turning the dough into
itself the dough should just sort of
relax
I shouldn't be sticking to your fingers
now it's just nice and pliable set that
there a nice clean bowl and we'll
sprinkly flour in there so as it starts
to rise just a stick cover that with
simple
leave the dough to rise in a warm place
for sixty to ninety minutes until it's
doubled in size this stage is called
proving now whilst that's proving Ella
panel
for the chocolate filling or ganache
pour five hundred mils of double cream
into a saucepan and add honey bring the
mixture to a gentle boil traditionally
we always put jam in there but chocolate
and downers Wow
to die for have the cream now give that
a good mix the butter elevates the
ganache into a really nice shiny
chocolate coat that will give it a
really nice whisk the wissen gives it
that aerated texture to the ganache so
just lightening the load a little bit
nice chocolate filling done put it in
the fridge to cool then it's time to
gently roll out the dough just let it
roll naturally but a centimeter and a
half in depth slice one to place them
off its your tray and let them rise
again once the donors have had 30 to 40
minutes to rise it's time to shallow
find them in a pan filled 1/3 full with
hot vegetable risen but look they're
sort of little pockets of air right here
we go place these in nice and carefully
for maximum if there's too many in the
pan the oil will go cold and the donuts
will come out soggy
peaceful they'll come out into some
sugar mixed with some malt paola 50/50
how do you tell they're actually cooked
in the center tap on top it should be
hollow in just sprinkle the malt and the
sugar shake off the excess I get so
excited every time I make donuts now
there's beauties these are delicious
each and as they are but the ganache is
gonna be the icing on the cake
piping bag peel the bag over your hands
don't forget to pop the nozzle in I want
the texture almost like a little liquid
inside some a pipe bomb and a little bit
warm hopefully where that bursts of
magic operation donut lift up the donor
squeeze push in and fill just do you
start seeing a chocolate oh yeah sit
that back down
[Music]
nice
sit them on there and got a little bit
heavier and we all know why
nice that one's got my name on it
that is amazing
[Music]
next my tricks the trade and kitchen
tips starting with how to do your steak
the way you want it I want to cut my
steak rare so by touching the steak on
the same feedback as it is on the inside
of my thumb that's rare as it starts to
cook they gets a lot firmer medium is
their semi firm with a slight resistance
well done is their rare a great tip for
getting meat or fish to cook faster is
to score it which allows the heat to
penetrate quicker this also allows
mayonnaise to be absorbed more deeply
for stain-free Tupperware and cut it
thinly with oil which acts as a barrier
between plastic and food it's so easy to
make your own chili sherry - using quick
stir Fry's or sauces take 450 mils of
dry sherry such as Fino and using a
funnel pour into a sterilized bottle and
5 hold tight chillies sill with a cork
or lid and leave to infuse for a couple
of weeks my tip for using any discarded
chili seeds is plant them to grow
yourself some new Chili Peppers plant in
an eggshell or seedling trays start them
indoors and move outside when they're
ready
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and a
hundred recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking